you had a background that probably a lot
of fans of yours aren't even completely
aware of which is you're born
in england
your dad's white your mom's black she's
into fat she's an incredible fashion
person who's designing clothes for david
bowie
all these fascinating people and you
come from
this and then you move to california
well no i moved to california my uh when
i was like really young right so six
years old right so my mom
basically she was based in los angeles
my dad's in england she had gone to
paris they met over there and then
so they were my dad was dying to get out
of england right didn't get along with
his folks and so so
we moved to los angeles because that's
where her her work was and then he
started working in l.a but it's this
fascinating sort of combination of first
of all it's a it's a literal melting pot
of cultures but also fashion that's
always been
part i think of
the look was always important to you as
well as the sound is that um is that is
that fair to say well i mean you know i
was very aware of clothes obviously
because that's that was what she was
into
for me though i mean i i guess yeah i
guess a look is i mean i always wore
t-shirts and jeans i haven't i haven't
changed my
sort of fashion
uh
structure
since i was six right um so i don't know
if fashion was so much the thing but i i
definitely was aware of of the fact that
that you have to have some sort of a
persona or an image you know because all
the people that she worked with um when
i was a kid growing up i was always
around it and these people were all
bigger than life so there was definitely
an entertainment because you know she
worked in the entertainment business on
in all facets from tv people to
musicians and
everything in between they all had this
this amazing presence
whether it was the clothes or whether
they were just really outspoken or where
they were really flamboyant
yeah or whatever so i was aware of that
and i don't know if i applied it to
myself but i was aware of it you just i
mean certainly uh
i never knew that your iconic hat was
something that you i just also want to
point out that slash is drinking from an
iced coffee he's not rolling dice
we're playing uh game of crafts
while we talk but um
like the hat was and and i can relate to
this a little bit because um i know it
was just kind of almost an accident you
like
you shoplifted the hat yeah
i
stole it from a place called uh
retail [ __ ] melrose
let's give a shout out to retail [ __ ] i
remember this because it's run by enid
[ __ ] by the way it's there was two just
her name two stores there was leathers
and treasures and retail [ __ ] next door
and tami
tammy downs the singer from a band
called faster pussycat used to work in a
retail slot so that's how i remember the
name of it and i went in there and i
didn't have any money and and i always
used to wear
some sort of a hat it was just part of
the sort of completed whatever look you
had going on you had to have a lid
and uh and i went in there and i just
saw the top hat and it just spoke to me
i guess you know so i was like okay so i
i just you know i figured what the [ __ ]
i just walk out with it and see what
happens you know and uh and so i did and
then i went next door to leathers and
treasures and i stole a concho belt
and then went back to the to the
apartment me and axel were living in at
the time and we had a show at the
whiskey that night so i took the concho
belt and i cut it up and i put it around
the hat and i wore it for that night but
it just became a thing where
i just i really identified with it like
i wore it all the time yeah just it was
a way you pull it over your eyes you
could hide behind if you were really
high it was great great for bad hair
days it was just
it was
i had i had no intention of it being
this long-term sure
thing well i think nothing starts that
way but you start wearing the hat and
then it becomes
this thing that you probably tell me if
this has ever happened and you have to
be honest
you walk in okay you have to be honest
okay
you going you're going to a restaurant
they're having a real busy night it's a
nice restaurant you say hey i didn't
make a reservation ahead of time but
it's uh
two
you've got room for us and they say
i'm sorry uh we're just we're very very
full right now we we can't help you out
you go
i'll be right back
to the car
and in the back seat you open the case
and you take out the hat and you put it
on and you walk back in and go i'd like
a reservation for two and they go right
this way
[Laughter]
no i've never has that ever happened no
that's never happened okay but i tell
you that when it does i'll let you know